[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
حسن جمو
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
حيث تتفاعل قضيه الغارات على مواقع في
مدينه اصفهان وسط ايران تقول مصادر
ايرانيه انه يجري تقييم الموقف
هذه قرارات
هذه صور تفاصيلنا من واشنطن حيث قال
مسؤولون امريكيون ان السيدات المواقع في
اصفهان ياتي في وقت تبحث فيه واشنطن وتل
ابيب طرقا جديده لاحتواء ما يسمونه طموحات
طهران النوويه والعسكريه
اما هذه الصور ستاتين من رام الله بعد
ساعه من استشهاد شاب فلسطيني على ايدي
حراس مستوطنه كيدومين شمال الضفه الغربيه
في اجواء من الاحتقان على ضوء تطورات
اليومين الماضيين
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد ساعات من هجوم على مجمع عسكري قرب
مدينه اصفهان في وسط ايران مسؤولون
امريكيون يكشفون
ان اسرائيل نفذت الهجوم بضربه سريه بطائره
مسيره وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تنقل عن
مصادر ان الهجوم حقق اهداف ايران تعلن
تصدي للهجوم وتؤجل توجيه الاتهام حتى
استكمال التحقيق
بعد شهور من توقف المفاوضات ايران تتلقى
رسائل من اطراف الاتفاق النووي عبر قطر
ووزير الخارجيه القطريه قل ان الدوحه تسعى
لتوفير بيئه ملائمه لعقد جولات تفاوض
اضافيه بشان الاتفاق ووزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه يقول ان قطر تحاول اعاده جميع
الاطراف في الاتفاق النووي الى التزاماتها
عشيه الوصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى
الاراضي الفلسطينيه اسرائيل تشدد اجراءتها
ضد الفلسطينيين مصادره الحق في السكن
والاقامه والمواطنه لعائلات منافذ
العمليات تسهيل منح تراخيص حيازه الاسلحه
للاسرائيليين وتعزيز الاستيطان في الضفه
على واقي ازمه سياسيه وتراجع عن اقتصاديه
بدوا فرز الاصوات بعد دور ثامن من
الانتخابات البرلمانيه التونسيه هيئه
الانتخابات تقول ان نسبه الاقبال النهائيه
تجاوزت 11 في المئه بقليل
والمؤشرات تشير الى اضعف نسبه التصويت منذ
ثوره التونسيه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا اجراء الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات التشريعيه في تونس في ظل
انقسام سياسي وازمه اقتصاديه ومعيشيه
ودعوه للمقاطعه من طيف من المعارضه
وتسترعى نسبه المشاركه الانتباه كما كان
شان بالنسبه للجوله الاولى
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما
هي افاق المشهد التونسي على ضوء هذه
الانتخابات
14% قالوا ان المشهد يتجه للحوار بينما
قال 88% انه يمضي نحو مزيدا من الانسداد
وتوقع 38 في المئه استمرارا وضعي على ما
هو عليه هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على من
الصوت من الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وان تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره وزير الاقتصاد
الفرنسي يقول ان اوروبا ستواصل دعم
اوكرانيا ولن تسمح لبوتين بان يحقق
اهدافها
[موسيقى]
في اول تطور من نوعه نقلت جورنال عن
مسؤولين امريكيين رفيعين قولهم ان الغاره
التي استهدفت مصنعا عسكريا بمحافظه اصفهان
وسط ايران نفذتها اسرائيل بالمسيرات فيما
نقل مراسل اكسيوس عن مصدر المطلع ان القذف
استهدف بدقه اربعه مواقع مختلفه في منشاه
تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
الهجوم بالمسيرات واستهدف مصنع عسكريه
بمحافظه اصفهان وسط البلاد لم توجه ايران
ايتهانات بشانه لاي جهه ونسي لاي علاقه
بالهجوم تنقل هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن
مسؤول عسكري امريكي كبير تاكيده عدم قيام
اي قوه عسكريه امريكيه بشنها جمال او
عمليه داخل ايران
نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان اسرائيل هي
من نفذ ضربه سريه بمسيره استهدفت مجمعا
عسكريا في اصفهان بايران
وفقها هؤلاء ياتي في الوقت الذي تبحث فيه
واشنطن وتل ابيب طرقا جديده للمكافحه
عمليه ايران المزاز على الاستقرار بما
فيها تعاونها العسكري مع روسيا
نعود الى استعراض المسار الذي تطورت فيه
الاحداث بدايه القصه كانت باعلان وزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه احباطه هجوما غامض
استادف مصنعا عسكريا بمحافظه اصفهان وسط
البلاد تبين لاحقا انه نفذ بثلاث طائرات
مسيره صغيره الوزاره تاكدت لنا المضادات
الدفاعيه تصدت للهجوم وان الاضرار اقتصرت
على سقف المصنع دون الاضرار بالمعدات لجنه
الامن القومي وسياسه الخارجيه في البرلمان
الايراني اكدت بدات تحقيق بشان مجريات
الهجوم تمهيدا لاعداد تقرير واتخاذ قرارات
فيما قال النائب عن اصفهان في البرلمان ان
الترجيحات التي تشير الى وقوف اسرائيل
وراء الهجوم قويه لكن ذلك مرهون بالتحقيق
قلم مراسل الجزيره ان تلفزيون الايرانيه
عرض صورا لما قال انه حطام الطائرات
المسيره التي استهدفت الموقع التابع
لوزاره الدفاع في اصفهان مساء امس وتظهر
صور طائره مسيره صغيره مدمره اضافه الى
سقف المبنى العسكري المستهدف الذي تعرض
لاضرار
حدث غير اعتيادي في ايران منشاه صناعيه
تتعرض للهجوم المكان مدينه اصفهان ايران
والهدف مصنع
لوزاره الدفاع يتعرض لهجوم من الجو تقول
وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه انه نفذ بثلاث
طائرات مسيره دون تقديم مزيد من التفاصيل
لكن وكاله الانباء الرسميه وفرت بعض
المعطيات
وسيارات
محمله بقنابله صغيره نفذت الهجوم تقول
ايران ان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت واحده
وانفجرت اثنتان واكوبتر مسيره تطير
لمسافات قصيره نسبيه مزوده باربع مراوح
وقادره على حمل قنابل صغيره
[موسيقى]
انا من طهران الدكتور عماد ابشناس رئيس
نقابه مراكز الابحاث والدراسات في ايران
مرحبا بك سيد الشمس ماذا قرات ايران بهذا
الهجوم وهي التي تعتبر ان ترجيح قيام
اسرائيل به هو احتمال قوي جدا
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين في الواقع يعني
الاحداث المشابهه التي حصلت في السابق
تؤكد ان الكيان الصهيوني عاده ان يقف
وراءها هكذا عمليات ويستخدم لاجراء هذه
العمليات عماله
منظمه خلق الارهابيه هؤلاء عاده يقومون
هكذا عمليات مشابهه في السنوات السابقه
قاموا بهذا العمل اليوم الوضع في همم داخل
الاراضي المحتله متازم بشكل كبير جدا وعلى
الارجح ان اتصور انهم ارادوا يعني اراد
الكيان الصهيوني ان يلفت الانذار عما يحصل
في داخل الاراضي المحتله لانه كان هناك
عالميه كبيره بالنسبه لما حصل
في اصفهان في حين ان ما حصل حتى لو كان
همم همم المقصود منه هجوما يعني كان هجوما
فاشلا ويعكس نوعا ما افلاس للقيام
الصهيوني في قيامه
بعمليات في الداخل الايراني ان يقوم
بعمليه بالكوات كابتر يعني هذه يمكن ان
يكون لمجرد هل يمكن ان يكون لمجرد لفت
الانظار عم يجري في اسرائيل حاليا امر
بهذه الخطوره وربما تكون لديه تداعيات
كبرى امنيه وسياسيه على المنطقه همم هدفه
فقط همم توجيه الانظار مما يحدث في في
اسرائيل
يعني الذي حصل اليوم هو ااا كذلك يعني لو
كانت العمليه مثلا انا اعطيك مثالا ايران
طيرت طائرات دون طيار طارت ااا 3000 كلم
دخلت الاراضي المحتله وعادت ولكن الكيانه
الصهيوني قام بهذه العمليه عبر الكود
كابتر والعمليه كانت عمليه فاشله يعني حتى
لو هذه الكواد كابتن همم نجحت في الدخول
وتنفيذ عملياتها الكود كوثر تحمل حوالي
مثلا كيلو او كيلو جرامين من المواد
المنفجره وهذه حتى لا تستطيع تخريب المبنى
يعني هذا الذي يؤدي الى التشكيك بانه يريد
لفت الانذار خاصه وانه في نفس الوقت كان
هناك عملاء جاهزون للتصوير يعني مؤسسات
اعلاميه تعمل مع اعداء ايران كان لديهم
عملاء هناك جاهزون للتصوير لكي يصوروا
ويرسل مثل ايران ناشونال الموجوده في لندن
لديها مصورين جاهزين هناك يعني من قبل هذا
يفتح المجال للسؤال عن الاختراقات الامنيه
خصوصا اذا كانت الطائرات كما ذكر قد
انطلقت من داخل ايران لكن اسمح لي انه
ارحب بضيفنا من واشنطن كيف كتمان كبير
الباحثين في معهد الشرق الاوسط والمتخصص
في شؤون ايران ودول الخليج العربي سيد همم
كيف مرحبا بك
ربما لاول مره يسارع كما ينقل عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان اسرائيل هي من تقف وراء هذا
الهجوم ما هي الرسائل التي ارادت اسرائيل
توجيهها من خلال هذا الهجوم استنادا الى
ما قاله المسؤولون الامريكيون ولماذا
تنصلت او بالاحرى تبرات الولايات المتحده
من هذا بسرعه
لا اعتقد ان الامر يتعلق بتشتيت الانتباه
عما يحصل
داخل اسرائيل والقدس هذه في هذه الايام
هذا
امرنا واضح لان
الايرانيه مع روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا ايران
الان تقوم بتخصيب اليورانيوم الى مستويات
اعلى والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قالت
هذا الاسبوع عند ايران لديها
مواد مخصصه
لصنع سته اسلحه سته اسلحه
عمليات التخصيب الاضافيه وايضا هذا هو صح
هو الامر بالتاكيد ان ايران الان تنتقد من
قبل العالمين
النساء وايضا عمليات بيع المسيارات الى
روسيا روسيا ارتكبت اعتداء ظالما على
اوكرانيا وايران تقدموا يد العون لها
بالتاكيد انه عندما تقوم ايران بمساعده
مثل هذا الاعتداء فهنا لك قوى مثل اسرائيل
ومثل الولايات المتحده سترغب بمعاقبتي
ايران وايقاف هذه البرامج برامج المسارات
والبرامج الصواريخ وهذا حصل وانا اعتقد
انه سيستمر اذا استمرت ايران بتسليح هذا
الاعتداء الروسي الذي يحصل الان في
اوكرانيا
تزويد ايران لروسيا بمسيرات اعود اليك سيد
عماد اجناس في مساله ايران تبحث اتخاذ
اجراءات
للرد اذا تاكدت او حمل اسرائيل مسئوليه
هذا الهجوم ما نوع الرد الذي يمكن ان تقوم
به ايران او تدرسه باختصار ارجوك
اولا بالنسبه للولايات المتحده يعني الضيف
لما لربما لم يشير الى مقاهه قامت به
الولايات المتحده
عمليا الولايات المتحده كانت قد ارسلت
رساله مع وزير الخارجيه القطريه اليوم الى
طهران وتصور ولو كانت تريد ان ترسل رساله
عسكريه لما كانت قد ارسلت هكذا الرساله
الدبلوماسيه الى الايرانيين وهي تناسلت عن
هذا الموضوع لتاكد انها لا دخل لها
لربما حتى لا علم لها حدث
الرساله
هذا النشاط همم
المتعلق باستئناف ايضا تزويد نعم
رد الايراني سالتك عن الرد الايراني
نعم
وايراني يمكنها التزويد كل معارضي اسرائيل
بانواع الاسلحه لكي يقوموا بنفس العمل في
الداخل الاسرائيلي يعني اسهل شيء هو ان
يسلمه الفلسطينيين
الكويت كابيتر تكون محمله بالمفجرات ويتم
ارسالها الى اي مكان الكود كوبتر هي
متوفره في اي مكان يعني كل المصورين
يستخدم
الكاميرا ويركب متفجرات يعني هذا ابسط شيء
ممكن ان تفعله ايران ولكن في الظروف
الحاليه بما ان الف فلسطينيين يقومون بحفل
تكريم ل همم نتنياه وحلفاءه انا اتصور ان
الايرانيين سوف يسمحون للفلسطينيين او
يساعدون الفلسطينيين للتكريم نتنياهو اكثر
مما همم من هذا الذي يحصل اليوم هناك يعني
لم يخرجوا الحفل عليه
طيب ابقا معنا السيد
كتمان من واشنطن
مشاهدينا لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نشرح
بالتفصيل الموقع الذي تعرض لهجوم
بالمسيرات في اصفهان ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن
الدلالات والتوقيت
والرسائل ايضا
بالانتقال الى الملف النووي الايرانيه
الذي تطرق اليه ضيفنا عماد اديشناز قال
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الاهيان ان طهران تسلمت رسائل من اطراف
الاتفاق النووي عبر قطر واشار في مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك مع نظيره القطري الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الرحمن ال ثاني الى دور الدوحه الفعال
في المحادثات بين بلاده واوكرانيا
اتعب يستلمنا رسائل من اطراف في الاتفاق
النووي بواسطه دوله قطر ونشكرها على دورها
الايجابي من اجل اعاده الاطراف لاتفاق
النووي والتواصل الاتفاق المثمر ايهما
الساعه تبذلها قطر للتوصل الاتفاق واي
وجهه نظر تقدمها نرحب بها هناك اقتراحات
قدمها الشيخ محمد بخصوص المحادثات
العسكريه والسياسيه بين ايران واوكرانيا
التي اقيمت في عمان لقد بذلت قطر جهودا
مشكوره وتقوم بدون فعال في المحادثات بشان
اوكرانيا
من جانب قال وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني ان الولايات
المتحده حملت الدوحه بعد الرسائل الى
طهران في موضوع يخص الاتفاق النووي
والقضايا المختلفه المحيطه به واشار الى
ان الفرصه الان مؤتيه لحل المشاكل المحيطه
بهذا الاتفاق تمهيدا لخلق ارضيه مناسبه
للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي حسب تعبيره كما
شدد على اهميه تعزيز الامن الاقليمي
وضروره خفض التصعيد في المنطقه
كان لدينا فرصه للحديث عن اهميه تعزيز
الامن الاقليمي وخفض التصعيد في المنطقه و
دوله قطر ودول مجلس التعاون ايضا تشجع على
الدخول في حوار وفق مبادئ قانون الدولي
وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه للدول
واحترام حسن الجوار وهذه العلاقات التي
نريد ان نبنيها مع جميع جيران
نعود الى ضيفنا من واشنطن وطيران سيد همم
كيف كاتزمن من واشنطن يعني في الاونه
الاخيره همم اعلنت بوضوح الولايات المتحده
ان الاتفاق النووي لم يعد مطروحا على جدول
الاعمال في ظل تطورات الحرب في في
اوكرانيا ما الذي استجد حتى تبعث الولايات
المتحده عبر قطر برسائل في هذا الخصوص الى
ايران
القبول
هو ليس على الاجنده هو مختلف عن انه ميت
اتفاق ميته اذا ما ارادت الولايات المتحده
ان تاخذ بعض المسؤوليه المباشره
لهذه الضربه اليوم التي حصلت في اصفهان قد
يعني هذا الامر ان الاتفاق ميت او انتهى
وقد تبتعد ايران عن الاتفاق بشكل نهائي
واوروبا ايضا لا تريد لان هذه المفاوضات
ان تنهار بشكل كامل بالتالي هنالك اهتمام
اوروبي امريكي
لم يكن مسؤوليه امريكيه واربيه يعني هنا
العمليه وايضا القول ان اسرائيل كانت وراء
هذه الهجمه او الضربه التي حصل فيها لكن
هذا الامر لا يغير من حقيقه ان ايران قد
جلبت المشاكل
لنفسها انا اتوقع ان يكون هنالك المزيد من
الضربات او الهجمات من اطراف اخرى اذا ما
استمرت ايران بتسليح روسيا روسيا يتم
ادانتها عالميه في كل انحاء العالم وايضا
انا متفاجى من ان قيام النظام الايراني
بان يربط نفسه بهذا الاعتداء على اوكرانيا
لايران المشاكل لحصول المشاكل اذا ما
ارادت ايران المشاكل ستحصل لديها مشاكل
يعني غير واضحه او غير واضح مضمون هذه
الرسائل حتى الان ولكن هل ايران همم جاهزه
ومستعده لقبول رسائل من الولايات المتحده
والتعامل معها
بايجابيه في ضوء ما استجد مؤخرا من تطورت
يعني عمليا كما قلت ليس هناك ليس واضح اما
كانت الرسائل ولكن هناك رسائل عديده ارسلت
لايران خلال همم
ساعطي ان اقول لك خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
او ثلاثه اسابيع الماضيه عمليه ما كان
متفقه عليها ان يتم ااا التوقيع على مسوده
الاتفاق التي ااا وصلوا اليه في مارس
وبعد ذلك كان هناك ايضا مفاوضات في الدوحه
تم الاتفاق على بعض النقاط كان متفقا ان
يتم التوقيع على هذا الاتفاق ولكن
الامريكان والاوروبيين تصوروا ان الاحداث
التي حصلت من ايران ممكن ان تعطيهم فرصه
لكسب امتيازات اكثر وحتى بعضهم تصوروا ان
النظام في ايران سوف يسقط ولهذا تريث في
التوقيع على الاتفاق اليوم بعد ان تاكدوا
ان همم الظروف لن تتغير
نظام في ايران مستقر ليس هناك همم اي
تغيير سياسي في ايران همم هم همم يعني همم
يرسلون رسائل بانهم مستعدون للعوده الى ما
تم الاتفاق عليه همم
و يريدون همم
ان يعودوا الى الاتفاق ولكن ايران بات
لديها بعض الشروط التي تصر عليها وهم لا
يريدون ان ينفذوا هذه الشروط شكرا للدكتور
عماد مش ناس رئيس نقابه مراكز الابحاث
والدراسات في ايران وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
واشنطن
الكبيره الباحثين في معدل الشرق الاوسط
والمتخصص في شؤون ايران ودول الخليج
العربي
[موسيقى]
التطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث قرر
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
تعزيز الشرطه الاسرائيليه بسرايا من الجيش
لمساعدتها في القدس والمناطق القريبه من
خط التماس جاء ذلك خلال الاجتماع
ضد الفلسطينيين
موقع مخلوق
قرارات لتعزيز الاستيطان فهذه رساله
للارهابيين الذين يريدون اقتلاعنا من
ارضنا نحن هنا لكي نبقى كما طلبت من رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي دراسه بعض المقترحات
التي اثرت في المجلس المصغر وسنخبر
الجمهور بها لاحقا نحن لا نبحث عن تصعيد
ولكننا مستعدون لكل الاحتمالات جوابنا
للارهاب سيكون بيد قويه ووردنا سيكون
عظيما سريعا ودقيقه
ويقول الفلسطينيون ان سياسه هدم المنازل
بحجه عدم ترخيصيه استراتيجيه اسرائيليه
عابره للحكومات تهدف لتهديد الوجود
الفلسطيني في القدس المحتله بشكل اساسي
وفي مناطق الضفه الغربيه بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
انت عام 48 دمرت اكثر من 500 قريه
فلسطينيه هدمت اكثر من 170,000 منزل ولا
حاجه او حجه لقوانين او مبررات تمريرات
مختلفه للحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه
لعمليات الهاتف بالاضافه الى معاقبه منفذي
العمليات وذويهم اسرائيل اي منازل او
منشات في المناطق التي تصنفها عسكريه لكن
العدد الاكبر من عمليات الهدم ينفذ تحت
ذريعه البناء دوره ترخيص البناء دون ترخيص
هو ترجمه الاستراتيجيه تهجير الفلسطينيين
من المناطق المصنفه جيم في حسب اتفاقسه
تلك مناطق تشكله اكثر من 70% من مساحه
الضفه الغربيه ابرزها الاحياء الشرقيه
لمدينه القدس المحتله اكثر من 100 مبنى في
القدس الشرقيه هدمتها سلطات الاحتلال
للعمل الماضي وفق مكتب الامم المتحده فقد
هدمت سلطات الاحتلال ايضا قرابه 4050 مبنا
في منطقه الغربيه هذه الارقام هي امتداد
استراتيجيه الاسرائيليه المتوسطه نقل عن
بنيامين نتنياهو وهو في رئاسه الحكومه عام
2016 قوله ان البناء الفلسطينيه غير
القانوني مرض يجب التخلص منه
تباهنتنياه حينها بان حكومته هدمت الف
منزل فلسطينيه في ذلك العام اليوم ومع
تشكيل حكومه تعتبر اكثر تطرفا يبرز اسمه
وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن جرير يصدر
الوزير الاسرائيلي الجديد تعليماته للشرطه
بهدم المنازل غير القانونيه في القدس
الشرقيه شرعت سلطات الاحتلال في هدم 14
منزلا في اني واحد مجزره حقيقيه يصفها
الفلسطينيون رغم ان اتفاقيه جنيفر الرابعه
تحضر على الاحتلال تمهيد عمليات الهدم فان
الفلسطينيين يعتبرون الامر استراتيجيه
ومنهجه لتهجير الاف منهم في محيط المسجد
الاقصى المبارك سبعه الاف فلسطينيه من حي
وادي حلوه والف و500 اخرين من حي البستان
ببلده سلوان واله اقامه ما يسمى الحوض
اليهوديه المقدس تمهيدا لهدم الاقصى
واقامه الهيكل المزعوم هذا مثال على
استراتيجيه الهدم الاسرائيليه في القدس
المحتله يهرق الامر المنظمات الدوليه لما
يشكله من خطر سياسيا بعيد المدى
جبل المكبر جنوبيه القدس اخر منزل هدمه
الاحتلال حتى ساعه اعدادي هذا التقرير
يمثل رقما يضاف الى قائمه المنازل المهدمه
لكنه لمن سكنوه اكثر من مجرد جدران
هذا وقد وصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطونيو بلانكين الى القاهره في سياق جوله
تشمل الاراضي الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بهدف
مناقشه التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
والتخفيف من حده التوترات وكذلك للبحث
الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي في القدس وملف
حلل الدولتين وملفات اخرى
سياسيا كذلك يواصل المدير والاستخبارات
المركزيه وليامبرز مباحثته ضمن جوله
محادثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين قبل
الانتقال الى رام الله للقاء قياده سياسيه
فلسطينيه
ما انا من رام الله غسان الخطيب استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت مرحبا بك
دكتور غسان ما الجديد برايك فيما اتخذ من
اجراءات
وقرارات من قبل المجلس الوزاري الاسرائيلي
المصغر ضد الفلسطيني
هذه الاجراءات التي يجري الحديث عنها هو
مزيد من التسليح للمستوطنين ومزيد من
التشجيع لهم ومزيد من التوسيع
لمستوطناتهم ولرخص البناء للبيوت التي
يقيمونها بشكل غير قانوني بعد مصادره
الاراضي التي يمتلكها الفلسطينيون في
المناطق المجاوره للمستوطنات وخاصه في وسط
الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا في منطقه القدس
المحتله لانه المعركه الحقيقيه هي معركه
على الارض وتريد اسرائيل ان تحسن في فتره
الحكومه الحاليه موضوع السيطره على ما
يسمى مناطق جيم وهي المناطق التي همم يعني
تركتها اتفاقيه اوسلوه تحت المسؤوليه
الاداريه والامنيه الاسرائيليه يعني طيب
هل هل تسليح واو زياده تسليح همم يعني
بشكل ادق زياده تسليح المستوطنين يمكن ان
يساعد همم الحكومه الاسرائيليه في الوصول
الى هذا الهدف ضمن مناطق جين وتوسيع مزيد
من المستوطنات
لا اعتقد ذلك لانه بالمقابل الشعب
الفلسطيني الذي يمتلك هذا هذه الارض متمسك
بارضه
وبشكل شبه يومي يوجد معارك باشكال مختلفه
من الحده بين المواطنين الذين يمتلكون هذه
الارض والذين يسكنون في الكره المجاوره
للمستوطنات وبين هؤلاء المستوطنين وبشكل
اليومي تدور مواجهات في الطرق المشتركه
التي يستعملها المستوطنون ويستعملها
المواطنون الفلسطينيون وبالتالي هذه
القرارات الاسرائيليه سوف تزيد من حده
الصراع وسوها تولد ردود فعل فلسطينيه اكثر
حده من التي يشاهدناها حتى الان وبالتالي
تفاقم الاوضاع واا ترفع من وتيره العنف
والصراع الذي نراه حاليا
الاستيطان وهمم وهدم المنازل التي كانت
دائما حل انتقاد امريكي اللافته انها تتخذ
عشيه وصول انطونيو بلانكن الى فلسطين
المحتله وبالتالي
هل يمكن ان يكون هناك محاوله امريكيه
لفرمله ااه هذه الاجراءات بشكل او باخر
سيكون هناك محاوله من هذا النوع ولكنها
ستكون محاوله يعني عديمه الاسنان بمعنى
انها ستكون يعني محاوله لاقناع الجانب
الاسرائيلي بمخاطر مثل هذه السياسه
واضرارها على مستقبل العلاقه وحل الدولتين
وما الى ذلك من الكلام الذي لا تشتريه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولا تعيره وزننا من
غير المتوقع ان تضع الولايات المتحده ثقه
لان سياسيا وضغوطات سياسيا وراء مثل هذه
الكلمات وتدرك اسرائيل واقع السياسه
الداخليه الامريكيه وتدرك تماما ان
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه ليست في وارد
استثمار سياسي حقيقي جدي في هذه المنطقه
من النوع الذي تحتاج اسرائيل ان تاخذه
بعين الاعتبار لذلك اسرائيل سوف تستمع الى
مثل هذه النصائح ولكنها لن تاخذها على
محمل الجد وبالتالي لن يكون اي تاثير من
رام الله غسان الخطيب استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قالت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
في تونس ان النسبه العامه الاوليه
للمشاركه في الدور الثاني للانتخابات
التشريعيه تجاوزت 11% في انتظار اعلان
النتائج
كما سابقتها تقريبا مضت اطوار الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه في تونس
فلا اقبل كثيفا ولا حتى متوسطه على مراكز
الاقتراع في عموم البلاد
والى حدود الساعه السادسه
161 هي عدده مقاعد البرلمان التونسي
الجديد الذي كان يتالف من 217 نائبا وفقا
دستوري عام 2014 جاء الدور الثاني من
الانتخابات
مالا لاختيار اعضاء مجلس النواب الجديد
بعد نحو شهر ونصف من جوله اولى قاطعها نحو
90% من الناخبين لتسجيل اضعف نسبه اقتراع
منذ ثوره 2000 2011 ولم يحسم الدور الاول
سوى 23 مقعدا بينما لم يجرى الاقتراعه في
دوائر انتخابيه بالخارج عن هذه الانتخابات
يغيب المراقبون الدوليون بدواعي التشكيك
في مصداقيتها اما الرقابه المحليه فشكت في
الدور الثاني من اخلالات ومضايقه من بين
المشتكين مرصد شاهد لمراقبه الانتخابات
ودعم التحولات الديمقراطيه حيث اعلن ان
موظفي هيئه الانتخابات مانعوا عددا من
مراقبه من دخول مكاتب الاقتراع خلال
الساعات الاولى من فتحها واعتبر المرصد
المستقل ان اقبال الناخبين على الت كان
ضعيفا مثل ما الحال في الدور الاول
وبعيدا عن الاعتبارات الاجرائيه والفنيه
المرتبطه بعمليه الاقتراع يظل الاهم سياق
الانتخابات
فاقتصاديا يتراجع النمو وتزداد البطاله
وتنهر القدره الشرائيه لفئات واسعه من
السكان حتى ان وكاله التصنيف الائتمانيه
الامريكيه موديل
تونس الطويله الاجل درجه اضافيه مع نظره
مستقبليه سلبيه نظرا لما سمتها مخاطر حول
قدره البلاد على سداد ديونها اما سياسيا
فتبدل الانتخابات وفق قوه المعارضه تعميقا
للشرخ الوطني بينما يؤكد معسكر الرئيس
انها تتويج لمسار الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو الذي لا ينفك ذلك المعسكر يسميه
مساره تصحيح التونسيه
قال احمد نجيب الشابي رئيس جبهه الخلاص
الوطني التونسيه ان النتائج الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه اظهرت ان
90% من الشعب التونسي السحاب الثقه من
المسار الذي انطلق بانقلاب الخمسه
والعشرين من يوليو حسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
ومره اخرى قال لانه لا ينقر قياده المسلسل
الاجنبي الذي لا يعنيه
[موسيقى]
دقيقه من المساج الذي انطلق بانقلاب 25
ان تقدم الشكر الى كل مواطن رفض الخيار في
هذا المساء
وعن المشاركه
الداعي الى المقاطع هذه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل الحصاد كنت قد اجريتم مقابله
مع وزير الاقتصادي والماليه الفرنسيه
برونو لومير الذي يزور الدوحه حاليا
وسالته اولا عن اهداف زيارته وما حققته من
النتائج
مساء الخير
اولا تهنئه دوله قطر على التنظيم الممتاز
لبطوله كاس العالم التي حققت نجاح مدويا
منطقه الخليج في صوره عامه
بين فرنسا
للمزيد من تعزيز العلاقات الاقتصاديه
الاناشيد
في تاريخ الطاقه العالمي في اوروبا كنا
معتمدين اكثر من اللازم على الموارد
النفطيه والغازيه من روسيا راينا انه مع
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
في دول اوروبيه وبالتالي الخيار الذي نريد
الاستمرار به مع رئيس الجمهوريه وخيار
الاستقلاليه
الطاقه المتجدده وكذلك على المفاعلات
النوويه تعرفنا ان فرنسا من كبرى الدول
النوويه في العالم والاستقلاليه ايضا تعني
تعزيز التعاون مع دول تربيه نوع علاقات
وديه وماتنا مثل دوله قطر
وبالتالي التعاون بين تروى فرنسا
مبنيون على علاقه متينه من الضروري ان
نضمن لمواطنين هذا الاستقلال في مجال
الطاقه في مجال الانتاج الوطني ولكن ايضا
من خلال تعاون متين طويلاجل بين قطر
وفرنسا حول الغاز الطبيعي المثل
هل استجابت قطر لهذا طلب الفرنسي وهل جرى
الاتفاق على تزويد قطر فرنسا بالغاز
الطبيعي الموساد
من قبل دوله قطر وانا ممتلئ سمو امير دوله
قطر
الماليه وعدد من الفاعل من الجهات في قطر
ورايين انه بالنسبه لتوفير الغاز الطبيعيه
المثال الرد كان ايجابيا ايضا هناك نقاشات
ايجابيه
تعزيز الاستثمارات بين دولهتين
وسنعمل في الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله على
تحديدي القطاعات والجوانب خاصه بهذا الاسم
لكن الانطلاقه جيده وهي تتماشى مع حياه
رئيس الجمهوريه الفرنسيه وكذلك سمو الامير
قد قطر وهو يتماشى مع مصالحتين
حرب اوكرانيا لكن هذه الحرب تضغط في اكثر
من مجال على فرنسا وعلى دول اوروبيه اخرى
تحديدا في الجانب الاقتصادي والمالي نتيجه
المساعدات وزخم المساعدات المستمر من
اوروبا ومن بينها فرنسا لاوكرانيا الى اي
مدى تستطيع فرنسا الاستمرار بالالتزام
بالدعم العسكري والمادي لاوكرانيا مع ما
تشهد من همم غضب شعبيه على مالتي اليه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في البلاد
في السودان
كافه الدول الاوروبيه التي وحدت الصف
زياده اراضي الدوله
اوكرانيا
من دوله اخرى هي روسيا بدون اي مبرر بدون
اي سبب
اوكرانيا الى انتهاك سيادتي اراضيها نحن
في اوروبا في فرنسا نحن دوله حقوق الانسان
ونحن لدينا قيم ومبادئ نؤمن بها سياده
الدوله
ليس امرا يمكن ان نتراجع عنه بالتالي نحن
ندعم اوكرانيا طبعا لهذا ولكننا سنستمر
بذلك فلما ان هذا ضروري كان رئيس
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه واضحه حول الموضوع
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى دعمنا سندعمها كذلك
انا ارى ان الاقتصاد الفرنسيه قاوم حين
ارى الارقام ايجابيه بالنسبه الى فرص
العمل تتحسن انظر الى الاستثمارات من قبل
دوله قطر رضوان الاخرى هي في تزايد في
فرنسا لان فرنسا صارت اكثر دوله جذب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه في اوروبا
الاكثر نجاح اقتصاديا في اوروبا
اليه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه كان في فرنسا او
في باقي الدول همم
الاوروبيه
ويتمظهر هذا الغضب الشعبي
شيئا فشيئ في تظاهرات
كيف تتعامل فرنسا مع هذا الغضب الشعبي وهل
بامكانها تلبيه المطالب المرفوعه في اثناء
هذه التظاهرات لا سيما مشاهدناهم مؤخرا
اشكرك يشيطون الزنك يوتيوب
هذه المخاوف
مرتبطه بظاهره عرفناها في كافه العالم الا
وهي التضخم ترتفع اسعار الغاز والكهرباء
والنفط وكذلك المواد الغذائيه هذا كله
يثير الكثير من القلق والمخاوف
وهذه المخاوف هذا القلق تعسس بسبب الازمه
في اوكرانيا ولكنها اصلا التضخم كان موجود
قبل سمعت اوكرانيا
ومن ثم اتت ازمه اوكرانيا مما عايزه
ارتفاع الاسعار اذا هناك
نحن في فرنسا مع رئيس الدوله لقد اعتمدنا
خيانه استراتيجيا حمايه الاسره الفرنسيه
وكذلك الشركات ضد ارتفاع الاسعار لقد
وضعنا نظام ومعانا للطاقه لحمايه مواطنين
من ارتفاع اسعار الغاز والكهرباء وبالتالي
كان مستوى التضخم وعدد تضخم في فرنسا هو
فعلا الادنى في كافه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا هو نجاح رئيس موريال ماكرون الذي توم
انا المخاوف كذلك هناك نقطه قلق اخرى له
علاقه بسلاح نظام التقاعد لدينا ولكن يجب
علينا ان تفسر ونقنع المواطنين ان هذا
النظام
هو لحمايه نظام التقاعد في فرنسا
لم يعد يعمل
نظام التقاعد هو جزء من المشكله وليس كل
المشكله ما دامت المؤشرات في فرنسا كما
تقول هي همم مؤشرات ايجابيه واا الاداء
الفرنسي كما تقول هو من افضل همم الاداءات
في في اوروبا
اذا ما الذي يمنع من سلبيات مطالب
المعترضين والمحتاجين بشكل مستمر في فرنسا
اذا كانت اذا كان الوضع مبشرا الى هذا
الحد
واكرر مره اخرى
جيد جدا في اوروبا الارقام تظهر ذلك نحن
نتحدث عن كل الاصلاحات التي
نفذناها منذ بدايه الرئيس
عن سياسه جيده للشركات
وكذلك
دائما الاصلاحات في مجال التقاعد تثير
المخاوف حين نطلب من المواطنين القيام
دائما
يخافون يقلقون يقولون لقد عملته لفتره
طويله من حياتي اريد ان اتوقف اريد ان
اتقاعد لا اريد ان استمر بالعمل
طبيعيه ويجب ان نعالج هذه المخاوف وهذا ما
نقوم به مع رئيس الجمهوريه مع الوزاراء
ولكن اص نظام التقاعد سوف يعتمد والدوله
الفرنسيه سوف تعمل بطريقه اكثر واحده كان
على امل ان نحقق المزيد من النجاح
الاقتصادي باختصار اخير سيد الوزير عندما
اشارت الى همم الدعم الفرنسي لاوكرانيا
شملت الدول الاوروبيه هل كل الدول
الاوروبيه بنفس مستوى
الحماس للاستمرار في الدعم العسكري
والمادي والاقتصادي لاوكرانيا باختصار
كوتينه
فقد اعتقد انه يمكن
ضعيفه جدا
وغير موحده الصف وبالتالي سوف لن تتحرك هو
قد اخطاؤه لقد اخطا في حساباته لقد توحدت
اوروبا
من هذا النزاع في اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى هجوم اصفهان لم يذكر
بيان وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه تفاصيل عن
الموقع العسكري الذي يتعرض للهجوم فاشل من
مسيرات حسب البيان
وتفيد المعلومات القليله الصادره من سلطات
طهر عن ان الموقع المستهدف هو مجمع عسكري
تابع لوزاره الدفاع يقع شمال مدينه اصفهان
بواسطه البلاد وان الهجوم كان باستخدام
طائرات مسيره فصدت لها الدفاعات الجويه
الايرانيه تلك الدفاعات لما كانت من اسقاط
احدى المسيارات
مسيرتان قبل ان تنفجر قالت الوزاره ان
الهجوم لم يتسبب في اي تعطيل لعمل المجمع
العسكري وانما احدث فقط اضرارا طفيفه في
صف احد المباني
كثيرا من مواقع الابحاث النوويه المعروفه
في هذه المنطقه بما في ذلك محطه الرمز
لتفصيل اليورانيوم
اياتي الاعلان عن هذا الهجوم في سياق
متوتر على خلفيه استمرار الخلافات حول
الملف النووي الايراني واتهامات بعض الدول
لايران بامداد الجيش الروسي بطائره مسيره
في اطار الحرب على اوكرانيا
خبر
عن مسؤولين امريكيين والذي يفيد بان
الغاره بالمسيرات في ايران نفذتها اسرائيل
لم يكن مفاجئا بالنظر الى هجمات صادقه على
مدى سنوات الماضيه شكل البرنامج النووي
الايراني هدفا لحملات عده منها هجمات
الالكترونيه ومحاولات تقريبا وعمليات
اغتيال استهدفت علماء اتهمت اسرائيل
بتنفيذ عدد من العمليات السريه على اراضي
ايران بينها هجوم ادى الى مقتل عالم
الفيزياء النبويه البارز محسن فخري ساده
في نوفمبر عام 2020 واحمل الطاهران تل
ابيب مسؤوليه تنفيذ عمليه تخليليه في محطه
في يوليو
2020 اتهم الموساد الاسرائيلي للوقوف وراء
العمليه التي استهدفت مرفق النوويه مختلفه
فينا في ابريل عن واحد و20
كما اتهم بشنه هجوم على منشاه نوويه اخرى
في كرج في يونيو عام واحد و 20 معنى من
مدينه ليدز البريطانيه الدكتور صالح علم
استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق الاوسط في
الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه مرحبا بك
دكتور لو لاحظنا بان معظم المواقع التي
كانت تتهم اسرائيل
بالهجوم عليها كانت مواقع لها علاقه
بنشاطات النوويه ايرانيه هذا المصنع هو
مصنع تصنيع عسكري هل لتغيير نوعيه الاهداف
دلاله معينه
هذا نوع من الهجمات لم تكون الجديدات كانت
هنالك جماعه مماثله قبل هذا منذ 2020 من
قبل الاسرائيليين في مراكز عده عن كانت
عسكريه ام النوويه وايضا اختيالات لعلماء
النوويين وبعضهم العسكريين في في داخل
ايران ولكن
هنالك تداعيات لهذا النوع من الهجمات اولا
انها فشلت لكي تقيد التطور العسكري وتناول
الايراني لا بالعكس انا طهران همم استطاعت
بسرعه وبسهوله ان تعيد بناء همم هذه
المراكز او مصانع او مواقع العسكريه ان ام
النوويه خلال السنوات الماضيه وثانيا ان
ان هذا النوع من الجماعات همم
فشلت اللي لتغير السياسات الطهران النوويه
ام العسكريه في نفس الوقت فاذا همم بما ان
هذه الاضرار من قبل هذه الهجمات من
الطائرات المسيره الصغيره جدا كانت طفيفه
وقليله جدا فلذلك همم لم تنجح لوصول الى
اي هدف ان كانت همم عسكريه ماديا وان كانت
سياسيه
تطرح تساؤلات ليس فقط عن الجهه المنفذه بل
ايضا عن الجهات همم المسهله والخروقات
الامنيه في الداخل الايراني خصوصا في ظل
الحديث الايراني
عن ترجيح وايضا حديث امريكي ربما عن ترجيح
ان تكون الطائرات انطلقت من داخل ايران
لا شك ان هذه الطائرات كانت صغيره جدا فلا
تستطيع ان ان تطير بمسافه طويله جدا هنالك
مسافه اربع الى سته كيلو مترات فقط تستطيع
ان تطير فلذلك
اكيد
حصلت هذا الشيء في داخلي ايران
ولا ننسى ان هنالك معارضه ايرانيه ومنهم
المجاهدين همم الخلق
القاتلين في الالبانيا اليوم همم
يساهموا او يساهم في هذا النوع من
العمليات مع الاسرائيليين ولكن ما ما يميز
هذا هذه الهجوم همم من باقي
الضربات اللي كانت مماثله في في القبر هي
ان في هنالك كما يبدوا اكثر من بلد ما همم
ساهمت في هذا هذا الهجوم همم كما يبدو في
هنالك ابتلاف وان اسرائيل ايضا
همم ساعدوه بعض الدول في في في فيما يلاحظ
بهذا الهجوم انه ربما الاكثر وضوحا وبسرعه
لم اا يعني لم يكن هناك حرج في ان يتحدث
مسؤولون امريكيون عن ان اسرائيل هي من تقف
وراءها يعني كان هو الاكثر وضوحا من باقي
الى هجمات لماذا برايي باختصار
نعم لا شك بمعنى الهجوم همم
لم تحصل على اهداف عسكريه
واضحه ولا سياسيا تستطيع ان تغير سياسات
طهران النوويه والعسكريه فاذا هي ليست الا
امر رمزي واشاره الى طهران ان اا ان
اسرائيل وحلفاء في المنطقه همم هم مستعدون
لمواجهه ايران في المستقبل ان لم تغير
سياساته النوويه والعسكريه همم
وايضا المشاركه في في حرب الاوكرانيا
ومساعدته همم لروسيا في هذا الامر يعني
عندما تتحدث عن كل هذه الاهداف تعود الى
النقطه الرئيسيه بان هناك اكثر من طرف
دولي همم مستفيد من هذه الهجمات ويريد ان
يوصل رساله بمعنى معين الى ايران ليس فقط
اسرائيل
العشاء كان لاول مره نسمع عن اسرائيل اييه
سنتوه الامريكيين وبعض الدول في المنطقه
كما يبدو هو الاوروبيين ايضا يريد ان
يرسلوا الرساله الى طهران انهم لا
يستطيعون ان ان ان ان ان ان ان ان ان ان
ان يقبلوا بان ايران وروسيا
يتحالفان في الحرب الاوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا
للدكتور على مصالح استاذ دراسات ايران
والشرق الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه
الاستراليه حدثنا من مدينه ليدز البريطاني
في هذا مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام الحصاد
لهذا اليوم شكرا
لمتابعتكم القاكم باذن الله غدا الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]